[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a california couple facing charges for a
road rage shooting
that left a six-year-old boy dead here's
a tennessee father admits to murdering
his five-year-old autistic son
but was it a false confession i got up
that morning
i got his clothes so i put the clothes
on the table
i went in there and he was gone author
and legal analyst dan abrams gives us a
sneak preview
into his new book on the trial of jack
ruby kennedy's avenger
it was the first time a murder that had
happened live on television
was tried shocking testimony in the
trial of millionaire real estate eric
charge
in the murder of his best friend what
susan berman allegedly told her friend
after robert durst's first wife vanished
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
everyone to law and crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
two people are behind bars in california
charged with killing a six-year-old boy
during a road rage incident
law and crimes angenette levy is here
with more on the arrests the charges
and more on aidan leo's anjanette yeah
brian this case has just shaken people
from coast to coast six-year-old aiden
leos was shot and killed
as his mother drove him to kindergarten
there are a few words to describe the
feeling produced by the despicable
actions
of that day over the last two weeks
finding the people who killed aidan leos
has consumed investigators
sunday evening marcus anthony aries and
when lee were taken into custody
after a 17-day manhunt we have recovered
what we believe
are the weapon and automobile used in
the crime
the california highway patrol says aries
fired a gun from this white volkswagen
as lee drove along the freeway in orange
county on may 21st
aiden's mother had previously said a
vehicle cutter off
aiden was in his booster seat in the
back seat when he was shot
why so much interest in this little boy
and i think i i know the answer
it's because it could have happened to
any one of us aiden's family remembered
the sweet six-year-old at a memorial
service last weekend
his mother joanna cloonan said he was
like an angel
who wasn't meant for this world
throughout his life
he was always smiling and laughing
his eyes would sparkle every time he
shared a joke
giggling while awaiting your reaction
he just wanted to make people laugh and
feel happy
marcus aurez is now charged with murder
and shooting into a vehicle while his
girlfriend winnie lee
is charged with being an accessory after
the fact to murder when she was first
arrested she was being held on a murder
charge
but now the d.a says he doesn't think
they can prove that at this time
so he's going to ask her bail to be
reduced from a million to less than that
uh they will ask that ariza's bail be
raised from one million
to two million dollars brian thanks and
jeanette
joining us today is civil rights
attorney katie smith and terry austin
katie the gunman aries is being charged
with the murder and discharge of a
firearm
and the prosecution has already said
they're looking for sentencing
enhancings
uh break that down for us absolutely
brian
in every state there are restrictions on
what types of penalties
certain crimes carry for example
murder for a reckless acting california
can carry a seven-year state sentence
but with the enhancements so these
add-ons
it can be extended to up to 25 years and
some of these enhancement are
for example gun enhancements whether
minors were involved which of course
would be applicable here
hate crimes gang crimes of course not
all of these are applicable
but you only need a few to be able to
enhance it beyond what would statutorily
be required
makes sense looks like they're really
trying to throw the book at him based on
not only the crime but the victim here
terry the passenger lee though as you
heard from engineer is only being
charged with accessory
after the fact and a misdemeanor why do
you think she wasn't
charged with either accomplice to a
murder or even murder as originally was
charged
well the lesser charge of accessory
after the fact is going to be
much easier to prove the prosecution
only has to show
that the individual somehow aided the
person who
actually committed the crime and under
the higher charge of an accomplice
liability
the authorities would have to show that
the driver
had the same sort of knowledge and
intent that the shooter actually had and
i think
under these circumstances that's going
to be more difficult to prove so they
probably looked at the evidence
and decided that they would do the
lesser chart
makes sense and jeanette the da's office
had a presser before the arraignment
what happened there yeah they talked a
lot about
just how much the community the
outpouring from the community really
helped solve this case the news
media kept it out there hoping to help
be a part of solving it
and also there was this huge outpouring
from the community in getting the
reward money raised to 500 000
they haven't determined just yet who's
getting what part of that reward that
kind of is ongoing sorting all of that
out but they really commended the
community
uh for coming together and wanting to
find the person
or people who did this to young aiden
absolutely this is really quick thinking
and helped by the community coming
together to find these two
of course we're hoping that there can be
some justice for aiden in this case
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily
vlog crimes founder dan abrams speaks
about his new book
kennedy's avenger and the trial of jack
ruby but first
was it coursed the jury in the joseph
daniels trial here is his confession for
the first time
welcome back a tennessee jury is now
hearing the alleged confession of a
father
accused of killing his five-year-old
autistic son lovingly called
baby joe joseph ray daniels reported his
five-year-old joseph clyde daniel
as missing on april 4th 2018. after days
of searching
the 31 year old father admitted to
murdering his son
but he later recanted with his defense
team calling the confession
coerced only two and a half hours of
daniel's four-hour interrogation was
played in court
prosecutors say daniels came to the
police station of his own free will
and could have left at any time before
his confession
daniels told multiple variations of this
story i woke up
i got to woke up about 11 30 that night
and he peed in the floor
i went into the bedroom i saw the pee in
the floor the the bathroom light was on
so i said you know let's go ahead and
just go back to sleep and he laid it
back and went back in the van went down
i went back to the bed and went back to
sleep
and sometime during the night crystal
got up
and she went out and checked on him and
then she went back to sleep
i woke up at 5 30
and then see that's that's when you love
stuff out
this next version is almost identical to
what the defense alleges
really happened daniel says he yelled at
the boy for peeing on the floor
then went back to bed
i got out of bed
went got to close alex and joe's
i noticed the coffee table had removed
that then i put the clothes on the
coffee table
i didn't look at the door
and i saw that joe was missing
i freaked out
i went
and got and looked through the house
first
i got crystal up to come outside with me
to try and find baby joe
then daniels confessed to beating his
son to death he was unable to lead pleas
to baby joe's remains which have never
been found yet
did you lose track of how many times you
hit him
i don't know how many times you just
kept in
from revealing he was laying on the
table complaining on the table
just just scratched he had cut his leg
on the table because they're going to
take when you don't
see any part though when i woke up that
morning
but what made you stop
when i realized that i lost control when
did he
stop responding it didn't
stop responding
he kept screaming the whole time
and didn't build
back with us a civil rights attorney
katie smith and terry austin
terry what do you think about the
agent's interrogation techniques during
the confession
i actually think it was very effective
brian particularly if we look at the end
result they started off
asking very broad questions the very
first question was tell us what happened
and then they sort of went into a more
accusatory process they used a version
of the read
process i think here where they said
specifically
well so what did you tell crystal what
did you tell alex
but they didn't put words in his mouth
so i think at the end of the day they
ended up asking
very good questions and they got the
confession they needed without actually
spoon feeding
the defendant now katie the defense is
going to point to daniel's body language
tone fatigue
to show this was a false confession but
do you see any signs of a false
confession here
you know brian it's tough to tell
because you really need to look at the
video in its totality for example where
the actual questioners were situated in
proximity you can see how close they
were how closely pressed upon him they
were
obviously his mental state and if he
does have mental health issues
weighs in favor of coercion but he does
appear to be relatively relaxed
he doesn't appear to be too caged in a
corner that's one thing that we always
look at
and he does appear to be feeding
relatively consistent
information so i think a lot of this
will turn on whether they offer
any type of expert about his mental
health status
yeah if they're going to argue something
along the lines of false confession or
coercion that's attached
to his mental health we would expect to
see the defense put on a case what do
you think terry
yeah i agree i think they'd have to put
something else on the stand to show
whether or not he had some mental
illness and whether or not this was
actually coerced i think
as we've all said it was just right
there where they got the right
information that they needed
all right we'll see how this plays out
as it continues thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily if
anything happens to me
bobby did it the chilling words susan
berman allegedly told one of her close
friends
but plus we speak with dan abrams on his
new book
about the kennedy assassination and the
trial of jack ruby
stay with us
we're back a new book is out on the
trial of the man who killed
president john f kennedy's assassin our
own jesse weber spoke with the book's
author
who just so happens to be the founder of
the law and crime network dan
abrams do you remember jack ruby the man
who shot
lee harvey oswald the guy that shot
president
kennedy well ruby's incredible trial is
the subject of
kennedy's avenger assassination
conspiracy and the forgotten trial of
jack ruby
written by abc chief legal analyst and
founder of our very own law and crime
network
dan abrams when i was reading this what
amazed me is that if this trial of ruby
aired right now on long crime
it would probably be one of the most
watched talked about debated trials that
has
all of those elements that people are
fascinated with right
and and you know it almost was televised
uh it almost became
the first mega televised trial
um there had been uh one or two other
televised trials
and the defense in this case wanted the
case televised the judge wanted the case
televised
the prosecution did not want the case
televised
and the judge got so much heat from the
local dallas community
begging him not to televise the trial
that he ended up effectively you know
caving he allowed the verdict uh to be
shown live
but that's it and look i think that that
was
a mistake in retrospect television was
new back then right they didn't know
as much as we know now they wouldn't
have been able to you know have the
the single camera that we have in
courtrooms and be able to ensure
that the protocol of the courthouse and
the courtroom
um is exactly as it is with a camera or
without a camera
but there were a lot of things that i
think it would have helped if the public
had been able to see
in this case the public was fascinating
with this case in 1964 as you can
imagine
yeah this was effectively the kennedy
assassination trial
and a lot of the conspiracy theories
that came from
the kennedy assassination were born out
of the ruby trial
questions that went unanswered hints and
suggestions the
defense saying the prosecution we want
you to stipulate that lee harvey oswald
acted alone
prosecutors we're not stipulating to
anything oh
why not what's the reason a lot of that
kind of stuff happened in the context of
this case but
this is it was truly a fascinating case
and and i am
embarrassed to say that i really didn't
know that much about this case
uh coming into this and was just stunned
at how rich the story was no i feel like
there's a lot of people that don't know
about it including ruby's defense
i mean if you ask people do you know
what ruby's defense was can you walk us
through that
and also not only what the defense was
wasn't he represented by quite
the lawyer like quite the character
lawyer himself
yeah i mean like he was represented by
the guy who was probably the best known
lawyer in the country
at the time his name was melvin bella he
primarily did personal injuries
uh cases um he used a lot of
demonstrative
evidence you know he'd throw things on
the floor and do stunts etc
but he'd done some criminal cases etc
and his defense in the ruby trial
was that jack ruby did not remember the
incident
that he was suffering from
a rare form of epilepsy that he had an
epileptic
event and that jack ruby didn't remember
it happening
and so he didn't understand right from
wrong and therefore
it was an insanity defense and you know
studying this case carefully
i think that the better defense would
have been the one that he was going to
use when he was granted a new trial and
there's another
fascinating element to this case is that
the verdict was overturned
and he'd gotten the death sentence he
should have just said
yeah i i did it i did it in the heat of
passion because you know what in the
state of texas back then
what was called murder without malice
that we know is manslaughter
in most states up to five years that's
it
no more than five years in prison is
what jack ruby could have gotten
if he'd gotten this murder without
malice
incredible trial and a great read jack
ruby died before he was able to be
retried
the book kennedy's avenger is now
available when we come back
the eerie last words of the murder
victim in the trial of a millionaire
real estate heir
robert durst what susan berman allegedly
told her friend
before being shot next
[Music]
welcome back jurors in the robert durst
case are continuing to hear
more bombshell testimony in the trial of
the millionaire real estate heir
charged with murder
and she would discuss that with me
friends of susan berman describe her as
vivacious
exuberant and outgoing the 55 year old
was gunned down inside her benedict
canyon california home
in december 2000
well i knew he was part of the jewish
mafia
and that he was from he was from
minnesota
after berman's death rumors swirled that
the shooting could have been a mob hit
but 15 years later authorities would
arrest her best
friend robert durst for her murder she
enjoyed
he was everything for her as far as a
friend
and my brother barnes says she
remembered one day back in 1982
berman calling her with a sense of
urgency saying she needed to come over
to tell her something important
that's when barnes says she learned
durr's wife kathy was missing
when she isn't got nervous
and she said i did something today
and an independent statement was if
anything ever happens
the testimony was recorded in 2017 and
both sides stipulated it would come in
at trial
rather than having the witnesses travel
during the pandemic robert durst
now 78 years old is standing trial in
california
his defense maintains he didn't kill
berman and doesn't know who did
on cross-examination the defense asked
barnes how she connected berman's
statements
that she did something to kathy's
disappearance you came to those
conclusions through your own supposition
correct
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and the defense asked barnes more about
what susan berman was like
as a person a lot of issues
yes
yes and last three mental health issues
on redirect barn says she didn't come
forward with what berman said for four
decades
because she was afraid of durst after
berman's funeral and after she learned
durst killed and dismembered his
neighbor
morris black in texas i was involved
and i tried to
[Music]
not use bobby's name when i spoke to you
i was editing myself because i was
scared
katie what did you make of the defense's
cross-examination there
did this argument that uh she came with
her own conclusions
helped the defense absolutely i mean
that's
really the connective tissue here
nothing that was directly
perceived seen heard by the witness
was directly on point this was all
exactly what the defense attorney said a
supposition that was pieced together
and honestly that usurps the province of
the jury the jury is the one who's
supposed to draw these
connective dots and here the witness is
the one who's
drawing the dots in this very bombastic
evidence i think that there's a lot of
problems with this and the jury
could easily disregard what this witness
says
all right terry put it all together for
us does this interest the prosecution
closer to be on a reasonable doubt or
not
well you know i agree with katie i do
think that there's so much
doubt as far as this individual is
concerned but it did help the
prosecution because
basically what you have is someone
saying that
she was told that susan berman did
something and that if anything happens
to her it was
bobby and the real question is do you
believe her
and why did she wait so long and the
fear that she had made complete sense if
you ask me
she sees all these people dying around
her she sees that you know kathy durst
is gone morris black is gone and
obviously susan berman is gone
so that put fear in her and she didn't
say anything for
many many years so i think we will have
to see what the jury says
i think the prosecution made some points
but clearly there is doubt here and i
could see the jury going either way
yeah definitely on the fence here but to
your point terry
there's a lot of arguments defense
attorneys make about late reporting
this one i think kind of makes sense as
to why someone would wait to report or
out of fear
as we understand thank you both for
contributing and thank you for joining
us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you